what's going on guys this is Rob and
it's snowing here in Lexington the worst
snow that we've had and god I don't know
maybe 15 20 years it's it's pretty bad
over the last few days so because I'm
stuck in the house I figured I'd make a
video so there's been some recent
discussion as to the idea of a sinister
six film coming out sometime in the
future so that's what we're going to
talk about in this video in this video
we're going to talk about the original
sinister six and what possible
characters they may include in the
upcoming Marvel film
so I think that when people think about
the sinister six they have this tendency
to think of the group being a sort of
Marvel version of a villain group like
the secret society of super villains
from DC Comics the secret society of
super villains from DC was a group that
was formed secretly by the villain
Darkseid and it was a group that was
designed to directly oppose the Justice
League of America but unlike the secret
society of super villains the sinister
six does not really exist to directly
oppose all of the Marvel super villains
I'm sorry superheroes as a whole instead
the group directly opposes spider-man
and the group was formed by Doctor
Octopus due to the fact that at the time
Doctor Octopus had suffered a series of
defeats at the hands of spider-man and
realized that the only way to really
defeat him would be to kind of put a
team together that would fight him in
stages that is to say that spider-man
would fight each member of the group
one-on-one in a location that would be
most suitable to their abilities and
with each person that was defeated
assuming that they were defeated that
person would possess a card which would
help spider-man who the next person was
that he would face and where he would
face them now at the time there were a
few things going on here of course Peter
Parker had lost his powers as spider-man
and it's really kind of speculated that
this is this was due to a mental block
over his guilt with the fact that he had
taken no action to stop the criminal
that had later killed Uncle Ben and so
because of this once the ensuing fights
or once the the battles begin to take
place he dons the spider-man costume
despite having no powers and goes to
fine electro who was his first first
opponent and then actually gains his
powers back now with regards to the
actual antagonizing action that really
kind of started the whole started
spider-man's involvement with the
sinister six storyline the sinister six
had kidnapped I guess Doctor Octopus had
kidnapped two major figures in Peter
Parker's life the first of course was
Aunt May his is basically kind of a
mother figure in his life and the second
was Betty Brant now a lot of people
don't know who Betty Brown
is and it's really kind of a shame
because Betty Brant was a great
supporting character and in the
spider-man storyline and she was a huge
part of Peter Parker's life in the early
days depending on who you talked to some
people will say that Gwen Stacy was
Peter Parker's first love some people
will say that it's Betty Brant but Betty
Brant and Peter Parker never really got
into as in-depth of a relationship as
Gwen Stacy or even Mary Jane Watson with
with Betty Brant and Peter Parker there
was chemistry there was a romantic
interest but not a whole lot was really
done about it
but despite this she still played a
pretty major role in in Peter Parker's
life and so when she was kidnapped along
with on May of course Peter Parker
really felt that he was compelled to act
now with regards to the defeat of the
sinister six of course it happens it
takes place and they all end up going to
jail but as time progresses we begin to
see different variations of the sinister
six come up in future comics the
sinister six actually the group actually
returns once pretty much all the members
of the sinister six come back together
again
after they break out of jail the
difference here is that one of the
founding members Kraven the hunter is
killed he commits suicide and as a
result the Hobgoblin takes this place
again there are different versions that
come along after that there's the
sinister 12 there is the sinister six
storyline from the Civil War timeline
there are a lot of different
incarnations that take place in a course
spider-man is successful in defeating
each and every one now as far as the
movie goes I'm really kind of interested
here because the original sinister six
was composed of of course Doctor Octopus
Kraven the hunter vulture electro
Sandman and Mysterio but we really
haven't seen any of these characters yet
and any of the Marvel multimedia
universe the only real exception of that
is of course the Fox films and that had
Doctor Octopus and Sandman as part of
the original members of the sinister six
and this film and the upcoming film the
amazing spider-man 2 we're going to see
elect
but that leaves a few characters to be
discussed that leaves Kraven the hunter
that leaves vulture
that leaves Mysterio and so I'm really
kind of wondering what direction things
are going to take and what characters
what kind of villains are going to
include in the new sinister six now of
course the villain Rhino which is being
played by Paul Giamatti had a role in
the sinister six much later on but they
may go ahead and add him in there but I
don't really know how they're going to
do it suffice it to say I'm pretty sure
that it's gonna have six villains just
come together and fight against
spider-man what I'm really hoping later
on is that after the venom story the
venom film they're not going to
incorporate him into the sinister six
because to my knowledge the Venom
symbiote
I guess as it was possessing or
possessing Eddie Brock didn't really
have any roles in any of the sinister
story laws although I could be entirely
wrong I'm I'm not as knowledgeable about
spider-man comics as I am about most
other comics but I don't believe that
venom really had a role here if I'm
incorrect somebody please post a comment
let me know but I really am excited to
see how this takes place I really am
excited to see how this plays out and
especially having a character having a
person like Paul Giamatti play Rhino
Paul Giamatti for me is really kind of
hit and miss in terms of the film's in
Saving Private Ryan minutes of screen
time and he was amazing
button lady in the water it was a
travesty to watch that film and it was a
travesty to actually see him in that
role so really kind of disappointing but
I think that regardless of what what
villains they choose to use regardless
of what kind of incarnation of the
sinister six they choose to use or if
they create their own version I think
it'll turn out to be pretty interesting
I think it'll turn out to be pretty fun
I'm just a little skeptical here because
in spider-man 3
we saw a whole host of super villains
come into play we saw venom we saw
Sandman we saw the Green Goblin the
second version of Green Goblin Harry
Osborn come back he was a villain at
first and was a good guy at the end and
I think that if the film is done in kind
of an a DD fashion and I don't say that
to offend anybody but if it's done
scatterbrained it can really kind of
destroy the film and so I'm hoping that
they
include different villains that
ultimately lead up to this point if I
had it my way I would do a film that
would be a precursor to the sinister six
that would show the sinister six kind of
coming together kind of you know maybe
organizing themselves and then
eventually have spider-man funny the
sinister six in a complete film where he
just goes from one villain to the next
and then ultimately successful in
defeating every member of the sinister
six and one of the coolest one of the
funniest parts about the sinister six
storyline who is at the end when Peter
Parker rescues on man she didn't even
realize she had been kidnapped she had
no idea apparently when she was with
Doctor Octopus he was extremely kind he
was extremely courteous and very
conversational with her and she thought
he was a total gentleman so just one of
those funny things I guess but with that
being said I'm gonna go ahead and ring
this video to him and I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know I will
catch you guys later peace